[Music]
Hey - mr. Monson you understand you're
trespassing right now right I have an
easement with the previous owner of your
property previous being the operative
word
it was this it's the guy told you to get
back in your nice truck go play okey
[ __ ] somewhere else
hey Carl looks like mr. Munson hire some
muscle looks that way
he's a friend of mine friend with a big
mouth they hear that a lot
and you probably heard this too more
than I'd like
and you know the drill I'll mow count to
three and you're gonna start walking
away yeah rice to this one I have a
lawyer now two three boss you know the
drill get the hell out of here
hello you know you got paid for that
right hey come on not okay we got
ourselves an x-men fan maybe a quarter
of it happens and not let this in the
real world people die Logan I don't want
to talk about it Logan
just stop be careful I need the girl
buckaroo go-getter
[Music]
[Music]
no no no and we're down
oh she's like you oh very much like you
oh not whatever it is you think I am now
she needs our help
someone to come off someone has come
along
this is what life looks like
people love each other home
you should take a moment
cela
you still have time
how sweet the sound